vous êtes la maman de lucie décédé dans
un crash d'hélicoptère dans l'émission
d'europe le 9 mars 2015 puis 6 mai dhabi
avait 36 ans
elle était journaliste pour l'émission
d'europe et maman de deux enfants en bas
âge déjà il est dit est ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter la tragédie que
vous avez vécu vous votre côté le 9 mars
2015 comment vous avez appris ça comment
ça s'est passé comment j'ai appris ça
mais j'ai appris sa part dans la nuit à
11 heures et demie du soir le neuf un
coup de téléphone bon voilà en fait
c'est pas directement la production qui
m'a appelé pc de la production appelé
son mari après son mois on se marie à
gérer les appels un peu tout le monde
dans la famille donc on apprend ça comme
ça 11 heures et demie du soir
ce quelqu'un proche qui me l'a dit donc
je m'y attendais pas du tout je pensais
qu'en plus je vais vous dire c'est
c'était sa belle-mère donc on se
partageait de les mercredis pour garder
les enfants dont je pensais qu elle
m'appelait pour le mercredi et jeudi
c'est bien le maple à 11 heures et demie
du soir mais non ne m'appelez pas pour
ça du tout et j'étais absolument sidéré
parce que elle devait rentrer très peu
de jours après donc je m'attendais
absolument à tout sauf à ça c'était
extrêmement incroyable et pourtant tous
les jours elle était déjà partie il
avait dû parti à voir fin février 25 26
ou plus exactement
donc tous les jours elle donnait un peu
des nouvelles pas pas tous les jours un
mois son mari bien sûr et je me disais
que ça il ya un jeu qui est passé
maintenant ça va être le deuxième elle
va revenir parce que on est une sorte
d'inquiétude a quand même vous étiez un
peu inquiète quand même vu qu'elle était
elle était donc elle était journaliste
pour des élections
voilà qui se passait dans différents
pays et c'est vrai que ça vous angoissez
passé elle avait déjà fait ce genre de
démission enfin pas d'europe ce que
c'est la chasse derrière bien repris
mais l'avait fait dès koh-lanta des
choses comme ça mon à aimer beaucoup ça
passait il ya un plaisir à travailler ce
genre d'émission on va loin dans des
endroits formidable ça vous ça vous ça
vous angoissez vous étiez inquiète un
peu déjà pour les collants tad moi pas
je parce que j'ai toujours défendu
l'idée que bon
bah mes enfants j'ai deux filles j'avais
de fait qu'est ce qui me plaisait c'est
qu'elle arrive à trouver ce qu'elle
avait envie de faire donc que ça leur
plaise et qu'elle soit contente et elle
dû signer mais beaucoup ça parce qu'ils
n'ont bien dans ces tournois mésaventure
elle est mais voilà c'est vrai que c'est
pas là on a pas d'heure on travaille
énormément mais on est entre amis on
fait des choses étonnantes mais voilà
c'est vrai que voilà lieux de vote dans
un bureau voilà je vois les cadreurs osé
qui sont ici voilà il adore il sur le
plateau mais c'est vrai que partir à
l'aventuré découvrir des baby ccc
vraiment dans des endroits formidable
oui et c'est un jeu en plus c'est bien
dramatique toriques mans donc c'est
haïti' été c'était le rêve c'est un peu
oui oui un peu le plaisir mais après les
on était dans une situation différente
parce qu'elle avait arrêté pendant un
certain nombre d'années passées à lui
des enfants donc effectivement quand
elle est arrivée à koh lanta l'avait nos
enfants un fils de 6 ans et une fille de
3 ans donc déjà je me disais mon beauf
est-ce que c'est devait partir la faire
c'est quand même sur trois mois donc je
sais pas je trouvais un peu plus tôt je
m'en mêlerai pas jeudi après tout on a
un mari ils ont discuté ensemble
s'organise et leur vie j'ai pas ramener
comme ça ma fraise en disant tu es sur
table j'ai pensé à tout et à autant je
sais que elle elle était angoissé parce
que l'émission était quand même c'était
assez rapide a commencé tout ça s'est
fait trop rapide donc alors et voilà
donc il y avait une sorte de pub on le
ce n'était pas évident en quoi un chien
par rapport aux autres émissions jamais
totalement évident dans les autres
émissions et s'est passé rue bizarre
mais là là je me disais bof
alors ouais c'était il ya cinq ans et à
5 ans comment on réagit quand on perd sa
fille en étant à des milliers de
kilomètres du drame
ben c'est vrai que vous avez raison de
parler de cette question des milliers de
kilomètres parce que c'est dé réaliser
c'est à dire que on a le souvenir de la
dernière fois
comme à chaque fois qu'on perd quelqu'un
d'ailleurs sauf dans une maladie ou mais
quelqu'un compères violemment comme ça
dans une sorte d'accident on a le soudan
on a l'image de la personne telle
qu'elle était hors ma fille n'avait que
36 ans donc a été tout joli tout toute
charmante ou de bétou tout voilà donc
j'avais cette image de quelqu'un
d'extrêmement vivent bien sûr
extrêmement content de vivre malgré tous
les problèmes qu'on peut avoir mon avis
comme tout le monde et d'un coût d'un
coup c'est fini quoi ça s'arrête on se
dit mal terminée je la verrai plus
jamais je pourrai jamais parlé avec elle
je pourrais je ferai c'est fini quoi
tout ça s'arrête c'est loin donc a pas
de cd réalisé
vous y pensez tous les jours depuis cinq
ans on doit absolument c'est à dire tous
les jours
ah bah oui mais ce n'est même pas tous
les jours c'est toutes les nuits tous
les jours tout le temps la peine la
peine est toujours là prêt oui parce que
c'est pas on n'a plus la même vie c'est
différent d'abord on doit faire face à
une quantité de problème absolument
monstrueux parce que dans une famille
comme ça c'est
c'est des gens qui réagissent très
différemment il ya des gens qui tombent
malades
il ya des gens qui se trouvaient à
l'hôpital il ya des gens qui font des
dépressions il ya des gens qui arrivent
des trucs physique absolument incroyable
bon voilà un an après je suis retrouvé
qu'une hémorragie je trouvais à
l'hôpital je pense jamais pris un
médicament j'ai jamais pris un somnifère
j'avais pris un anxiolytique jamais pris
un antidépresseur et un an après mon
corps a craqué donc je suis retrouvé
brutalement alors que j'étais en
vacances avec mes petits enfants
hospitalisés d'urgence qu'une hémorragie
intestinale énorme
donc voilà s'il vous arrive des trucs
comme ça et pourtant moi j'ai voulu
continuer à travailler
j'ai voulu faire tout comme avant mais
en même temps rien n'est comme avant
c'est à dire que il faut il faut on se
dit ben oui il ya des gens qui sombre
c'est bien kirk a des gens qui sombre et
on ne peut pas leur en vouloir c'est
sont constitués comme ça alors moi je
constituais différemment chacun est
constituée différemment heureusement son
mari n'a pas sombré mais son mari aussi
s'est retournée à l'hôpital avec un truc
incroyable bon et il faut il faut être
là quoi il faut être là et moi dès le
début de toute façon par rapport à cet
éloignement de vous parler moi la
première chose que j'ai eu envie de
faire c'est d'aller à buenos aires
revenir avec son corps ça me semblait la
folie de monsieur que reviennent comme
ça dans un avion avec les autres ils
étaient 8 et depuis lothar j'entends ça
déjà ça a été immédiatement une bataille
d'enfer c'est à dire que non on m'a dit
parce que possible des concessions
possibles jeudi mais si moi je veux ma
fille et une partie je pensais qu'ils
allaient revenir mais elle est partie
travailler
donc c'est pas en vacances ou sait même
pas comme comme ce sportif dont vous
venez d'évoquer le drame vivre rien
parce que oui je me rappelle ce sont
nous elle est partie travailler c'était
fait confiance à son employeur elle fait
en l'onu se réunisse tous savent tout
faire et sont très bien donc je dis bah
oui on va travailler c'est normal c'est
un boulot c'est pas jl part et revient
pas donc non comme a dit une autre
personne la lave
nelly les libyens qui a dit bah il est
parti et qu'une valise est revenue dans
un cercueil
ça alors moi je dis au moins que je veux
revenir mais je vais aller la chercher
je veux aller à chercher et alors qu'ils
aient pas fait abbas a été affreux parce
que romaric des jeux blizzard
bon je vous savez il ya des cellules
spéciales qui se met en place colonna il
passe à l'étranger que c'est à dire
assez c'est la boîte de production qui
doit s'occuper de ça la boîte de
production elle m'a dit non mais nous on
s'occupe que du voyage on doit emmener
les gens sur les lieux les des crashs
des machins mais ce n'est pas tout à
fait de l'année oui oui évidemment j'y
suis allé mais alors bon ah mais c'est
après mais on va dire maintenant mais
c'est pas prévu
j'aime et je m'en fous prévus par prévu
moi vous croyez que j'ai laissé ma fille
on va venir tout seul non mais c'est
même pas la peine vous et c'est
impensable
j'irai la chercher donc je me
débrouillerai pour la chercher et ils
m'ont dit dans ce monsieur j'ai dû jouer
là jusqu'à ce soir c'était un lundi
c'était une semaine après et simplement
une semaine après j'ai peut-être autre
chose à faire que de le battre mais tant
pis je suis j'ai pas le choix et j'ai
joué jusqu'à demain mardi
et si vous me dites mardi bah j'espère
que vous allez me dire vous allez
trouver une solution c'est vrai c'était
pas si simple que ça parce que les vols
soient pas une odeur c'est le dernier
avion que je pourrais prendre c'était 48
heures après le jeudi donc j'ai dit si
vous ne pouvez même pas imaginer ce que
ce que je suis capable de faire
ben j'ai travaillé 30 ans dans la presse
je ne sais pas ça du tout qui
m'impressionne donc moi je mettrai tous
en dessous mais je partirai et vous m'en
verrez que vous ayez réussi à bâgé
passivement mercredi c'est le jour je
les gardais mes petits enfants
voilà et j'ai pas simon mercredi à salé
7 heures du matin appelé les journaux
les radios des télés machin les trucs à
me faire interviewer je me souviens
j'étais avec mes petits enfants aux
buttes chaumont
on s'appelle la marionnette et paf life
et même téléphone bagis sorties sorties
gilbert payet je suis aux buttes
chaumont marionnette aux guignols et ben
je sors et ben oui je vais vous donner à
l'interview j'ai fait ça et le soir et
encore l'après-midi m'ont téléphoné en
me disant m'envoyer la psychologue en me
disant h tous appellent parce que son
très inquiet pour ce que vous avez très
très mal je vous croyais et je vais mal
parce que je vais aller chercher ma
fille non mais je pense que je vais très
bien au contraire c'est totalement
normal j'ai pas la laisser revenir tout
seul alors vous avez pas finalement ils
ont ils ont cédé la fin annoncée le
plancher dit vous savez là on est
mercredi
c'est demain que je peux partir après
ces attentats j'ai deux parties vous
êtes allé la chercher
ouais ouais mais même quand je suis
arrivé à l'est quand je suis arrivée à
l'aéroport c'était pas réglé en fait 8
ans en listes d'attentes et j'étais avec
mon mari est donc je dis vous êtes sur
listes d'attentes alors je suis dit je
vais balancer la bomba tant pis donc je
vais voir la dame qui me dit ça j'ai eut
dit vous savez pourquoi je veux
absolument prendre cet avion il m'a dit
non je sais pas ce que je cherchais les
huit corps là de l'accident d'europe a
été concerné m'a dit mais on nous a pas
prévenus pajiba voilà donc la hunaudière
front charmant d'ailleurs une fois que
je suis arrivé à buenos aires là où
maison production avait fait ce qu'il
fallait c'est à dire et qui fit et wii
avec quelqu'un qui était là tu as un
formidable tout tout à fait comme il
fallait
mais bon c'est des choses très
difficiles et quand on revient et on
sait que dans la soutient lui corps les
mord la queue
ben voilà on est obligé de faire ça mais
je me suis dit ben voilà ça va être ça
ma vie mais maintenant ça va être ça
parce que ça c'est rien c'est que dalle
ça c'est juste j'y vais je reviens c'est
normal mais après on va aller en
argentine j'y suis allé et d'autres
personnes d'autres personnes de familles
et vastine vous avez des contacts avec
les décomptes à vous voyez d'ailleurs
quand vous parlez cet accident
d'hélicoptère on a un groupe i what's
app ou aux migrants vous avez vu
l'accident d'hélicoptère du lait juste
avant alors c'est ça qui vous ça c'est
bien fallu à chaque fois qu'on voit ça
oui eh ben on voit les images similaires
ça bon voilà on voit des images très
similaires et on se dit en plus quand je
suis allé en argentine peut-être trois
semaines après l'accident je pense pas
tellement puisque ça quand on est allé
sur les lieux j'ai assez bouleversant de
revenir sur les lieux de voir ça parce
que justement il nous manque cette
matérialité là on a vu
des cercueils on n'a pas vu les corps on
n'a rien vu on n'a pas pu aller dans les
hôpitaux les voir donc on a le lieu et
le lieu quand on est arrivé ce qui était
absolument insensé c'est de l'accueil de
la population d'abord et ensuite sa
santé le feu on était un mois après et
sa santé quand il y avait les deux lieux
où les deux hélicoptères s'était crashé
évidemment il y avait plus les corps et
compagnie heureusement mais je tiens moi
j'ai ramené des choses de l'hélicoptère
qui bat après tout dans cette poussière
des bouts de fer du machin j'ai mis une
sorte de cadre je vais faire comment
vous avez expliqué à vos petits enfants
ce qui c'était passé
ben c'est pas moi n'ont pas paniqué
ouais il vous en parler vos petits
enfants après ou pas du tout vous on
parle bien sûr qu'on en parle puisque
d'abord on s'occupe de moi on est une
famille assez assez uni entre tout le
monde et oui on s'en occupe énormément
parce que c'est ça on se dit pour eux
pour leur vie moi mais la preuve chaque
jeu proche des revu le matin le mardi
matin c'est à dire tous les matins je
sais cette coutume là depuis 50 ans
sinon plus je vais toujours boire un
café au café voilà et là j'arrive dans
mon café
il était assez tous était 7h30 du matin
et il me dit vous êtes là bientôt et je
dis bien regardez vous allez là elle
parisiens qui étaient là j la une et il
ma fille élan photo en une il ya peu
sidérée donc voilà oui les enfants c'est
c'est absolument je plonge les ai vus la
première fois j'ai l'impression je
voyais des enfants dont ils manquaient
la moitié celui-ci leur manque la moitié
de la vie quoi de leur vie quel âge
aujourd'hui ils ont 11 et 8 6 à 50 et
donc je me dis ben comment ils vont
faire comment ils vont faire pour vivre
sans mère un truc comme ça qui vous
tombent dessus et voilà donc notre souci
évidemment pour eux c'est à la fois d'
c'est toujours très compliqué ce genre
de problème parce que on veut pas
oublier les gens on ne peut pas à les
oublier de façon c'est comme si on est
c'est comme si on moi je dis on a un
corps occupé comme on dit un territoire
occupé hier on vit avec quelque chose
dans son corps qui est autre chose on
n'est pas comme avant on peut plus être
comme avant
et en même temps il faut être aussi
comme avant c'est à dire ses enfants ils
ont le droit de vivre
il secondera de connaître aussi le
bonheur et moi j'ai eu ma fille 36 ans
c'était pas mal eux ils ont eu leur mère
trois ans donc on dit ça frotte père
d'un enfant mais j'essaie affreux perdre
un parent aussi six petits bonds après
sept années 2015 a été monstrueuse c'est
une super des attentats les machins à il
des multitudes de gens qui est arrivé
des choses encore aux synergies aussi
violente aussi inhumaine aussi atroces
mais là c'est très très particulier
parce que c'est pas
c'est un travail fou quand même c'est un
accident du travail comme et comme il y
en a pas beaucoup
il y en a même très peu et donc
évidemment on veut connaître la vérité
on veut savoir ce que c'est la
connaissez la vérité parce que là c'est
encore s'il ya une procédure judiciaire
en cours
la vérité évidemment qu'on la connaît
pas puisque enfin il ya quand même si
d'après vous la connaissez toujours non
non parce qu' une enquête comme ça qui a
lieu en argentine donc et une procédure
là bas bah c'est déjà un problème sur la
porte à côté
ensuite il ya aussi les juger ces
enquêtes ils sont allés ils sont aussi
allés on souhaite voir comment s'était
passée puisque le coup cette chose là
comme vous le savez pertinemment était
aussi une émission suédoise bon nature
là donc ils vont partout il interroge
tout le temps mais les gens malades sans
que ça dure mais ça fait cinq ans que ça
dure en plus la justice mental quand
même beaucoup de travail mais on peut le
dire ils passaient sans doute de gens
pour pour s'en occuper
donc notre dossier on voit là c'est le
pool des accidents des accidents publie
des accents collectif c'est le pôle de
santé publique sont pas énormément de
juger ils ont d énormes dossier donc
nous on est toujours là mais c'est pas
une archi priorité il ya des dossiers le
médiator la fac wade désossé énorme